this entire time i'm like literally  thinking how could i make that much  money and the only thing that popped  into my head was only fans oh hey  very brave very industrious very brave  of you if that's your passion  okay look i don't know if that's my  passion have you actually considered  doing this or are you just are you just  [ __ ] around i don't know i feel like  i usually [ __ ] around when i mention it  but then i feel like the more i talk  about it the more i'm like intriguing  there's a lot of potential in there it  doesn't have to be sexual yeah i know  that's right here yeah yeah like cat she  she doesn't show [ __ ]  so nonchalance  can't don't show a [ __ ]  i'm trying to get a house so like oh  well then let's talk real quick pitch  what do wet wednesdays  wet wednesdays and whatever that is to  you yeah dirty thursday  exact saturdays  that's two on the nose  today i think holocaust little  wednesdays